of the films that you have made which
one taught you the greatest lesson and
what was that lesson maybe it was an
accidental lesson yeah whoa my chances
we've you know Christina and I have done
a lot of work together but we've only
made three films and I think our films
are are sort of their sort of special in
a way because they take a long time to
make they tend to probably maybe have a
higher profile than some of the
television shows we've done or
commercials we've done our things like
that other projects we've done so i
think within our three films I mean
they're all very different they're like
our three kids I mean they're very
different from each other I think I
think they've all taught us lessons I
think wordplay really taught us that we
could do this you know that we we found
a story that was interesting to us we
that story also had a really big
built-in passionate audience will shortz
has millions of fans around the world we
knew that about him so in a way that was
the odds were stacked in our favor i
think when we started making that film
it hadn't been done before and we found
an audience so that was great and that
gave us a lot of confidence i think with
with I OH USA which was our second film
which also premiered at sundance that
was in 2008 it's just a very different
film it was a movie about economics it
was a nonpartisan look at the national
debt I think hmm I think with that film
we just I was just I just had a natural
curiosity you know economics and finance
and and politics are all things that I'm
interested in I'm certainly not an
expert in those areas but I got a chance
to speak to really some of the greatest
minds of our time about about economics
and about
the federal government and it's it's the
way it uses the national debt and I mean
I love that film I really I really loved
making it and I loved sharing it with
people so that was that was sort of the
key to that one I think as far as if you
build it if you build it was almost like
a back to the drawing board moment for
us it was so hard to make it did it took
longer to make that movie then our first
two films combined and and it was a
tricky story I mean the story was hard
there were two teachers and ten students
and a lot of people in this town they
were all really important to the story
that's hard to cut I mean that's hard to
cut that together with all of these
films you're telling a story that hasn't
happened yet so in the case of if you
build it we spent us one school year
with these kids how do you know who's
going to be important at the end of the
story when you start you don't so you
got to shoot out you got to shoot
everybody you got to do all their
stories you got to do all their
backgrounds and then as this as the year
progresses certain characters become
more important but you you need footage
from them at the beginning it's it's it
was hard it was hard to do that film but
I think if you build it kind of taught
us that you know not to get too
confident like we don't have it all
figured out you know it's it's
challenging to make these no matter how
much experience you have no matter how
much good fortune you've had and you
know I think with if you build it even
though it was really hard I love this
film I mean I I it's it really kind of
had a very profound impact on Christina
and I because our three kids are in
public schools and we're always
wondering well how do we as parents how
do we make this school better than it
already is and a lot of what we learned
and if you build it we've
lied to our own school we I think I
mentioned we started a kids film
festival at our local grammar school my
oldest daughter Fiona and I decided why
don't we do a film festival we started
it last year we just had the second one
recently that was a great way to do
something with the kids that sort of
speaks to the community I mean there's a
lot of filmmakers live in LA and live in
our neighborhood so their kids got to
make movies like their parents do and
the kids love it you know the kids the
kids make the movies themselves and then
we show them all you know in the
auditorium it's great so I mean every
every film is different it's it's um you
know it's it's you get a little
exhausted while you're making it and
then you release the film and you share
it with others and then eventually you
get to a point where you start to get
hungry again and you want to dive back
in
you